hey everyone welcome back to warlord
podcast i'm james marshall and i've got
a huge episode for you today but firstly
this episode is brought to you by the
woodland merch yes we have restocked in
hats and hoodies which were by far the
most popular items so if you enjoy this
podcast go and be a lad by getting
yourself your own lead hat or hoodie and
it's as simple as heading over to
waterloo.com also on that website
there's also discounts for mintwear
suzon and puresport cbd so go and make
the most of those discounts while
they're there anyway i've got a great
guest for today so let's get to it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a lad well i'm mixing up a little
bit today by not just having one great
lad on the podcast but two and who
better to test that new approach out
than having a couple of new zealand
legends who have both won commonwealth
golds and olympic silver medals for the
all black seven side and are both
starting in the bunnings npc final for
tasman after making a massive impact for
them this season they are two of the
great lads it is regan ware and andrew
neuster welcome lads
good to be here hey thanks for coming
out to the waterlabs studio out on mapua
sun is shining
[Laughter]
but boys tasman final this weekend who
would have thought you guys would both
be starting in a final at the start of
the bunnings cup yeah well
i guess
i'm pretty happy to just be playing bro
i um i thought i was going to take my uh
eight weeks leave and
be parked up on the beach with a few
beers so um
[Music]
just massive to be down here bro good
group of boys and this is this is my
first uh npc final twos
and you've played for a few teams too
yeah yeah being around
and you stubby how did it all come about
for you
i knew riggs has been in talk with the
tassie boys for a wee while and then
um obviously a few fellas went down so
um yeah got the message from goodie
luckily i was in the know of goody
before so yeah um yeah i'm gonna sit if
i wanted to come down give him a hand
and
i was yeah i always loved to come back
down here so yeah it's cool because you
were grinding away here for a while
before you got your chance hey
yeah i was i was down there for since
2014 was when i first came down and then
i was going away and
an old banter of bruce kept me out
yeah yeah i tried to hate bruce levi i
just couldn't mate he's such a good guy
yeah
i was like man he keeps keeping me up
but
it's too much of a good
um yeah and then i ended up making it
with the um with the seventh team and
then yeah but you guys you guys have
obviously added heaps to the um side
since you've arrived how have you found
coming into the tasman environment
yeah i've loved it bro um
i've been playing fifteens for a while
um
for a good year or so so
um coming in
you know that transition from sevens to
fifteens is a little bit um rough just
wrapping your head around all the calls
all the plays
um it's different when you're going from
defending seven people to fifteen
um but now like i said bro all the boys
are real welcoming helped out with that
a lot and um once i wrap my head around
fifteens
it's good too then yeah yeah jesus had
run around what about you stubby
yeah it was me and i was pretty like
comfortable coming down i already knew
like most of the boys and
everyone was um still the same when i
left so
saw some good laughs and it was just
cool to be on the other side not in the
sparrows
so what and what have you found the
hardest transition from sevens to
fifteen probably just like the time on
feet like you spend a lot of time on
feed and then talking about stuff for a
wee while and then
all of a sudden you just gotta flick the
switch again and start sprinting again
yeah um whereas at sevens it's kind of
just go go go
have your smoke go after um
but yeah i think yeah that's probably
the biggest on the more cooking they
more like punting and stuff like that
yeah just getting your head around that
i'll click once
it's kicking when you come down i was
shocked
or right footer
mate you've kept that under cover you've
been striking them real nice
also
i don't know about that bro
should i get better
i don't know if i'll call it good and
what advantages do you feel like you
have from coming from sevens probably
the fitness side of things yeah you know
coming out of a full uh
olympic campaign
pretty much straight into 15s it kind of
helps a bit
on the lungs
but like subsets it's a bit different
like time on feet
obviously 80 minutes compared to 14
minutes is a bit of a difference but
yeah i guess that's probably the biggest
thing is the old ones are a bit warmed
up do you struggle with the lungs at all
when you're playing fifteens or do you
find it pretty easy it's more like the
body soreness and stuff oh the lungs are
all good eh
yeah not too bad
now the lungs are good it's more the
cramping oh yeah pretty big cramp yeah
you cramped for the first time the other
day yeah
i don't know what was going on
i don't think i've played longer than 20
minutes
[Laughter]
cramp this weekend in the finals surely
and obviously like that fitness thing's
pretty underrated i reckon because i
mean it's pretty obvious to notice how
much fitter you guys are compared to
probably the rest of the group and
the energy you guys have on the field
and the ability to do those extra
efforts on the fields made a massive
difference for our side anyway probably
stubs more than me
but yeah it does help coming from a
full sevens campaign into 15
just a easier transition i'll say yeah i
wouldn't say it's easy but
it's a bit better yeah and stubby you
were at horowhenua before you came down
here you managed to sneak in a couple of
games for them so
how did that compare to the bunnings cup
um
oh i don't know how to say it
like it's obviously different like um
like the newer the newer boys are just
freaking legends they they just go to
work 12 hours a day
come out training but they've got sheep
[ __ ] all over their hands and they're
like all right let's get into some footy
training and they just give it to the
whole time yeah and then go out like
give up their weekends and play footy on
the weekends just because they love it
and just because they love the province
and the union and stuff and
um man i love my time for the new and i
like i always wanted to play for them
since i was a young fellow like watching
watching my older brother play for them
and and watching some other guys play
for them was it was awesome and then um
yeah i was just lucky enough to
have a couple games for them and i
didn't actually offer them very much i
was
i thought somebody i played center one
game and like yeah got punted a few
times
very humbling
do you find did you find it hard playing
at that level
yeah
yeah i found it just different i think
um
yeah there was a couple of times here
the ball was just kind of chucked to me
and expected to yeah do something
yeah yeah
yeah it's more just different i think
the bunnings is probably a bit faster
um and i think you know you make a
mistake in the bunnings and getting the
[ __ ] pretty fast whereas um heartland
you normally work your way out of it
sometimes yeah and obviously we've got
the final this weekend by the time this
is released that would have already been
played but how you guys feeling what's
the confidence levels like
no quite good bro um we've had a pretty
good week building up to the game
um
obviously i've had a week off so i'm
probably a little bit more fresh than
stubs is how is your head no it's good
bro that's pretty messed up to start
with yeah
but now like i said bro they had a good
week um pretty clear on most of our
roles so set to get out there on the big
stage and do it
exciting times you stubby i got to i got
the pleasure of rooming with you last
weekend so
i'm looking forward to seeing what the
rooming list is for this weekend
hopefully stu keeps it the same and i
get to have another night with you
is that a mutual feeling yeah
oh yeah well i think you two sort of
requested that haven't you because you
guys was was any part of your deal to
come down as long as it was both of you
i actually asked if i could come down by
myself
yeah once i heard he was coming down i
tried to pull out
[Laughter]
now but you guys have obviously been
good friends for a long time when did
that relationship sort of start was that
from sevens or was it before then
no it was it was just straight from
sevens like yesterday before i made it i
was i was just a fan so i knew
wow yeah i don't know if i was actually
a fan
got photos with them
autographed
i was a fan and then i met him and then
decided actually
[Laughter]
i went straight from here and um rig's
asked if i wanted to move him with him
like obviously we had a few camps and
stuff like that before and he said oh
you might as well come
move on with me and the missus and um
yeah i moved on with riggs and it was an
eye opener
really got to know riggs
build it for money
oh that's quality anyway boys um i had a
few questions about a lot of guys
wanting to know what your
pathway to the sevens game was like so
we'll start with you reg i know you grew
up in tokyo what was that like for you
yeah growing up was um was real cool bro
but you know like i loved it
um
i love the fact that i get to you know
call take my home yeah i'm still really
proud of it
and i guess my pathway bro i was told
till i was an intermediate and then i
moved up to hamilton high school
um and then from there i had a couple of
years of waikato
um then i got asked to go away on a uh
sevens invitational
sort of pre-season tournament the
central coast played their first
tournament um
and then about a couple of weeks later
titch called me up and
basically said he was going to contact
me from there onwards and sure yeah
i was probably lucky i had inside word
joe was betting for me quite hard jay
weber yeah yeah yeah so i probably
wouldn't be here unless he you know i
had the support of him so how did you
know him through school yeah i went to
high school oh yeah yeah yeah
so kind of
unfortunately for him stuck his neck out
for me and
yeah i probably owe a lot to joe um
got my name in the
in the workshop and from then onwards i
just had to put the foot down and start
working hard what is it about tokura
that so many people come out of there
and become successful i mean so many
athletes come from there it's crazy i
just want to get out of there
thanks bro
no but it's a pretty it's a pretty small
tna like the populations what would the
population be there ah
maybe 14 oh yeah i think
and about 7 000 of those are
professional athletes
yeah there's a few rugby players that
come out of tokyo so yeah um
now i guess
it's quite um
you know everyone and talks backing you
all the way um you got a lot of family
there
who still now you know come to most of
the games as many as they can come to i
always get about 30 40 of them
uh auntie's uncles
mom and
[Laughter]
they come to the seventh tournament said
um they'd have been in hamilton yeah
you know get the shirts on and a few
yeah
you're never short of support um
it's real family based down there and i
guess
you know with enough support and love
bro you go a long way
it's quite hard not to really personally
yeah
what about you stabby where did you grow
up
uh i grew up in and why can't i oh yeah
coast yeah um
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
and then come down here in 2014 like
i've seen and uh what what inspired that
move to come down here uh there was a
there was a guy that come down here um
one of my brother's mates uh early and
he worked for the
um
cup of rugby
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah he got us down here and he said oh
yeah they'll sort you out a job and um
accommodation
and like you know you hear that you say
all right
calm down i said uh
i was picking apples
i was so far
i don't know how i was getting paid less
than minimum wage because i wasn't
picking them up
[ __ ] them and throwing them at trees
and stuff
thinking you're coming down were you
thinking you're coming down as a
professional player or no no no i knew i
had to work and stuff like that but i
was actually just on trial for the
tasman academy oh yeah yeah yeah it was
pretty cool had a few fellas like davey
and um and ethan blackhead and stuff
like academy and stuff that was quite
cool
and then from there 2014 i tried to play
sevens for tasman yeah and um i actually
got dropped
and then i thought oh yeah
i'll just go home early then i went back
up to cover before christmas
and um went up there and i was training
with the sevens the horde of noah couple
d7s i just trying to stay fit now oh do
you want to play and i was like yes
sweet i'll play and then we had tasman
in our draw
and then when i forget it's a pretty
tasman team like shannon fazelle and
trey and tony and all that
and now we actually ended up feeding
them yeah yeah
it's one of my highlights i reckon no
how did you not make the tasman seven
side
yeah i was yeah i was probably 60 kgs
but you know yeah yeah that's just how
you fellow would you have packed yes
so you put on fire
[Laughter]
would you have picked yourself honestly
cool like if you were the coach do you
think you deserve to be picked from that
squad oh man i don't know
um just like i was one of the fittest i
was one of the fittest but
like i was pretty green you know i was
pretty fresh yeah and um
i don't know like i said they had a
stack team yeah and i don't really know
who they would have taken out you know
yeah
i don't know and it was mean to go up
and play for the noir and like i knew he
was guys up there so yeah that was mean
so then how did you go from the noah to
the new zealand setup ah yes oh so i
played the new and then the following
year i come back down
and um try to create tazzy fifteens and
missed out and then i played tazzy
sevens uh they picked me this time
and then uh i think after that it was
the following year i did the same
i actually got told
um from one of the followers out
and rework it to maybe think about not
playing sevens because i need to put
size on
60 kgs yeah probably need to put some
size on
and um i was like nah i love playing
seven so i played sevens and then i was
bloody lucky i did because me trail and
tony all got picked up in the same time
and then years into the into the camp
from there so we could mate how good is
that and how how was the camp how was it
going into that camp obviously regan was
already in there but um what was that
what was it like going into that camp
i was it was bloody nerve-racking like
we come straight out of the tournament
no like you know it just happened so
fast like oh yeah we got training on
monday and i'm like hang on just played
every single minute
and i was like
[Laughter]
yeah don't have a first plane and we had
to postpone it
and i'm sorry and then i was just like
where my body isn't but yeah going off
against the like
some of the best athletes in new zealand
yeah and um
yeah
yeah there's some fond memories i got um
paired up with
sharon styles and the first like
tackling drill oh he said he's like oh
um seen you play nationals you're pretty
mean like you got a pretty mean um right
foot stephanie
and i was like oh cheers
but it was tackle and he just read it
and set me on my head and i was like oh
done his homework yeah
there goes that confidence stuff i said
what about you riggs because you
obviously went in a few years earlier
was it one or two years before stubby
uh end of 2015
yeah so
maybe a year and a bit yeah and what was
it like for you because a few older guys
would have been there when you were
coming in there yeah i was pretty
nervous bro um
i think as our first training we've done
like a beat
speed and then
had a 10k training after that yeah so
that was that was the touch days where
you used to just kind of run that's
right yeah
i was crazy were you fat
reasonably not really no yeah no i
wasn't too bad like i just come off the
back of my 10. yeah but i guess
15's fitness compared to that type of
sevens fitness is a different ballpark
yeah and what weight were you because on
your wikipedia it says you're 101 clicks
you're definitely not 101 clicks
nowadays well i was
103 going into that camera were you oh
true so you were back yeah wow that's
heavy
i went in quite quite heavy and then i
think after that
week
of training and and their first tourney
i would have lost about six seven
[Laughter]
that you'll do that yeah probably three
or four in that one day it's crazy
so what weight are you at now
uh about 93 ish somewhere around there
is that the weight you're happy to be at
yeah yeah
obviously during sevens i'll probably
get a little bit lighter a couple of
kegs lighter a lot of running but
i said somewhere around 92 brian pretty
comfortable
nice and talk to me a little bit about
the sevens environment because i know
through my brief experience they used to
have all sorts of traditions like
um room flipping and blanket do they
still sort of things still go on
ah they've kind of you must you probably
were the big guy doing they say
well
it's kind of simmered down now over the
last couple of years
i don't think we've blanketed it anymore
we blanketed anymore
well not seriously i've heard some
stories
who's the worst one and what is a
blanket we probably probably should
explain it for the listeners uh
blanketing so i guess they just hide
around the corner when someone walks
past throw a blanket on them
tackle them or not tackling and kind of
just passion
did you ever get it no it didn't oh true
too much respect no it's because i keep
hiding from it
i got it on my first tournament did you
[Laughter]
how did you find it
yes good experience i didn't know what
was going on oh had you not heard about
them either nah nah just out of nowhere
i think riggs might have baited me
come in here stubs i've got a secret to
tell you
you rushed him
secret
and room flipping did you ever get your
room flip or is that sort of stopped now
too too much damage
uh yeah i got my room flip multiple
times yeah yeah
well the last couple of years that has
kind of stopped it kind of stops and
some ambi's one eight probably
for like four o'clock in the morning
like just a little bit of stuff
[Laughter]
the movies and stuff and
and then you come back and they're like
oh someone's you know they'll flip that
room and stuff and and obviously ambi
was busting to go
for a [ __ ]
and he went and
said an uncrowded soul and just shared
myself with the clogged taller and then
went to flush it and obviously it's just
everything just poo particles like
all over the carpet and stuff and oh
yeah it was shocking and then like it
was right next to the elevators as well
so you're like waiting for the elevator
you just smell the the shitty carpet
it's got food particles or
that was one of them
they had to wind it
shut it down oh [ __ ] there's a yard
and another yarn i've always wanted to
know the real story about is um the
slice of heaven that um clarky mentioned
on his what lad episode how he said that
you sung the slice of heaven and you
lost so then that was the end of it but
what was the real story there how did
the slice of heaven's song come about
uh
so
as you know we've got songs for like
every culture in our team and um
he asked me if i wanted to lead the
honky-white version and i thought
there's no better song than slice of
heaven
turns out that's not the software
um
oh yeah so
so i tried to take control and lead it
and i was only a young fella i was
probably only 22 or yeah or something at
the time and i was trying to tell these
guys how to do it and we're all pretty
tone deaf well the white guys are turned
deep anyways
[Laughter]
yeah so we did it before the game and
it was the french the french was sharing
the
change room with us
it was like the first time we sang it
and the french were like and the change
remember i don't even know if they spoke
english but they were just staring at us
like
what are you doing
so we just went through it and then
we're all laughing and stuff and then go
out and
nearly used to uruguay
and then i think we lost the next one
did you sing it for the next game as
well yeah because you normally sing the
song for the whole tournament
just before you go for warm up oh yeah
yeah i think it's more to switch the
brain on but yeah anyway it must have
been a bad omen because clucky said shut
her down
so he shut it down mid-tournament still
didn't win the tournament you know so
yeah and then we went to vancouver and i
was talking to dylan collier and i was
like
i was like [ __ ] it wasn't the song
there's nothing wrong with this song
in our room and he's like yeah
and then we left the bloody door open
and as we were saying that clark walks
past and he's like
[Laughter]
they were like oh yeah that was the song
[Laughter]
i don't know if much of you went into
that game we lost us and we sang the
song eh it's like yeah you look at all
the times we dropped the ball or you
know miss reads in d yeah first thing
like he says when he gets into their
leadership meeting is i think
[Laughter]
so do you have a honky song anymore or
did you change the song or is it just no
song that was just no song
yeah all the yeah
all the white guys like myself we're not
very good at this thing you know so we
just shut it down if you had your time
over what song would you go would you
stick to stick to your guns and stick
with slice of heaven one of the great
changes i'm still a big fan of dave
douglas i reckon he's a great new
zealander yeah
well you try to bring another sign don't
you
oh yeah crowded house yeah better be
home soon
and how did that go
ah yeah we shut that down as well
[Music]
oh good times in the sevens cam and also
a couple of games i want to talk about
2016 rex you obviously playing i watched
a little documentary on it last night
2016 final and there's this one moment
that happened this tackle from regan out
of nowhere you you talking over at a
little five minute docker was one of the
best watches i've seen for a scene for a
long time can you ever give the
listeners a little bit of insight into
that tackle and that doco first real
doctor
first of all bro the doctor
the follow up made me say everything
that i said
and i'd say something that was you know
i didn't really get into it much and
then he'd stop it you know say no i need
you to talk about it more
more like talk about it less you were
just talking about that tackle
it wasn't my choice
but there was obviously a massive
occasion uh back when the final was oh
the sevens were still in wellington
massive crowds back then a and uh you
had a pretty stacked team artie and the
yuani brothers sunnyvale
um and a huge final against south africa
so
um talk me through that whole moment
it's pretty nerve-wracking um that was
my first
final i was involved in
but yeah i guess like you said bro
there's
um some big names in that team augie
sonny
the iwanis
um you know and coming on i think
there's only about three minutes in the
game yeah and were down i was just like
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] this up
um
and yeah i guess it just turned out how
it did and
[ __ ] we were bloody happy after that all
right i went so we pissed off
because tit was pretty strict with that
sort of stuff eh yeah yeah
yeah he was um but i guess what tisch
doesn't know
[Laughter]
because there was all sorts of rules
like not allowed to eat red meat before
a tournament or during a tournament all
those sort of things
no red meat two days before
uh obviously no drinking
no no treats no treats no
we get roasted if we introduce yeah the
drawer
what's the drawer
one year man tell me we're rooming
together and um it was that was all
timmy's idea
said this massive draw and you pull it
out and there's about 40 snickers bars
and lollies and
other sort of things
in there
and he found it no i didn't they didn't
find it but
a measure yeah
every time we talk about eating [ __ ] or
something yeah we call it the draw
this brings us back to that time
oh it's good stuff another game or
tournament i guess was the
2018 commonwealth games you're both
involved
both won the gold medal so talk to me
about that tournament it was it was a
main main tournament um
so we had another pretty stacked team
uh leading into it we didn't really know
who was going to get picked and stuff
like that we had pretty good depth and
um
going into he had some
a whole lot of injuries like
caleb clark got appendicitis
um his when joey's
started playing enough hey what was it
yeah
[Laughter]
arthritis
yeah
he got that and then who else went down
villes nearly did his villi yeah he
nearly did his bloody mco or he didn't
have an mcl or something yet i mean like
that was something horrific but he was
running around on
half a leg going in every once in a
while
yeah
oh yeah he did his um ankle like the
week before
sure i think i've done my knees uh yeah
it was horrific but anyway we got into
the tournament and then i don't know it
was just a good buzzer and obviously
there's full crowds and stuff like that
and yeah i don't know it just kind of
all fell fell into place for us and i
think we played some pretty good footy
and
yeah like i said we had good deeps i
reckon so we always confident you're
gonna come home with the gold going into
that tournament and through that
tournament oh probably not a leading
into the tournament we were not looking
good um but i feel like that probably
gave us a good edge you know thinking
like geez we've got to be way better
than what we have been and what we what
we are currently so
gave us that good edge without being too
confident kind of just right on that um
good spot i think
same for your eggs yeah we had vancouver
our last world series tournament uh what
did we come sixth
you came sixth in the world series
oh yeah yeah yeah so we lost our fifth
and sixth playoff sure so that's not the
uh confidence boost
but
and then we we flew over a couple of
weeks early and played aussie in sydney
and i think our first game we got pumped
second game got pumped
heaps of boys went down with injury yeah
so it was um
the opposite of a confidence booster
yeah
and then a week before
um the weekend before
my son was born oh yeah so he was um he
was supposed to be due a month later so
a couple of weeks when we got back from
com games oh yeah so the plan was i was
going to stay back and not go to the
next world series tournament yeah he
ended up coming four weeks early
yes i flew over that weekend before um
stayed for a couple of nights and then
flew back on the monday
sure and yeah kind of just went into the
tournament nothing to lose really and
went for it yeah and the olympics talk
to me about the olympics
this was obviously a massive tournament
i got put put back a year so that was
probably pretty niggly to deal with but
going into that tournament how was how
was that
it was a big build-up like you said it
got postponed a year and um all the boys
didn't really know what was going to
happen yeah did you think it was always
going to happen
oh well they were kind of confident that
it was always going to go through but
obviously you've got your joe blogs who
decides to know what's best for the
world and you know i think it's not
going to go ahead
but you know it's pretty stoked they
went through
so we had a good year
um during the postponement where we kind
of just
well we actually couldn't go overseas
any tournament so
we had to create a few of our own
and
she was pretty tough not gonna lie yeah
you know just training for
you know what was it eight months
doing nothing but you know training
against your own team yeah yeah yeah
and it gets a bit niggly you know
because we all know the same moves so
yeah you try and run a move and the boys
just kind of shut it down
and
you know pluck balls over here
it's a little bit niggly but um
i guess in the end we we we got there
wasn't quite the result but
something to be proud of definitely yeah
what was it like playing at the olympic
games um yeah it was awesome um
obviously that took a long long time to
get to that point um felt like kind of
like five years really building up that
was always going to be the end goal was
to play there and yeah just to even make
the squad i think was it was a huge
achievement and then to get out there
and i think
like for me personally i think making
the squad was was huge because i just
had so much confidence in the boys that
um you know we're gonna we're gonna do
well we've been training really well so
um
yeah i think whoever we picked i think
we probably were going to go all right
so
um yeah it was awesome obviously there's
no crowd it's a massive stadium
but when you run out you kind of make
your own atmosphere and
it's huge huge occasion and just love
going out there and playing with the
fellas
and a huge tournament from you like
clarky put you as one of the best
players in the competition so
obviously
individually you would have been pretty
stoked with how you play
um
yeah yeah yeah there's obviously just
heaps of
heaps of um things i could have done
better than i got bloody bunted off a
couple times in that final against
fujian's yeah i think they really enjoy
doing that
i was very gutted about but yeah i think
um
yeah like i was fit as but
just when we went into the tournament
like we kind of hadn't played a full
tournament in a long time yeah
and uh when you're playing the world
series you can kind of get used to
playing every minute or you know a lot
of minutes and um hadn't played that in
a long time and and i went out and
played a lot of minutes and and i think
my legs just got all a bit of a fried
and went out to that final and
often i say to myself i'm like you know
you're not that tired yeah yeah you're
gonna push through but i think that was
the one time i'm like
geez
it's not just because my heat got taken
off
were you sort of hoping for a sub would
you have wanted to come off is that sort
of how you're feeling oh no no there's
no way like i think like if i knew i
couldn't you know do my best out there
then i would have said yeah like
but now i was still in a good position
to play well i feel like i didn't play
well but i was still in a good spot to
play well and yeah
what are the subbing rules in sevens is
how many subs are to make
you're allowed to make five oh true
that's quite a few uh yeah
um unfortunately that means two people
have to play full games
yeah it's usually them
you're running a bomb going i think you
can last yeah
broncos are so different
talk to me about your broncos that's a
question that came in a lot what time
broncos did both run
um
[Music]
around 14.
uh i think my fastest one was for 18.
yeah
that's fast you're both real hesitant
and yeah you know you know your scores
just trying to be harmful
i just love racing the old horses they
like scars and um and
yeah and to me who does the best one
who's got the quickest time
probably stops really
lately oh nice yeah but
but honestly if you if like you're not
on your game
to me on a good day yeah tell
[Music]
yeah
and the phosphate test you still do that
where you have to do the 10 40 meter
sprints no it's gone we stopped that
what does you ever do yeah
what other tests do you do now
we've kind of changed if there's a
broken bronco now how do you do that
what's that involved
uh so they they take your time uh
earlier in the week like how fast you
can do a broken bronco so you're 20 40
60 and it's kind of normally around 38
seconds 37 seconds and then
um
later on in that week it makes you do
five of them
uh on the two minutes
um but your first one has to be within
two seconds of your best time oh sorry
you've got to be giving it to soul time
and then they kind of just see
how much you've dropped off kind of like
a phosphate yeah yeah and um yeah i
wouldn't yeah i wouldn't advise anyone
to try that at home nasty is it the
break makes it worse yeah yeah you'd
almost think it breaks too long hey
because you can feel your lactate just
getting yeah and then you're like i
don't know if i can start this yeah
the first time we did it we only had the
30 seconds rest yeah we did it on the
minute 30. and we were just kind of
trolling it out and like
i was running a like i was sitting on a
broomstick i was like
jeez and i was just trying to beat him
by like a whisker every time
you know we could be doing something
that's real slow but every time i cross
the line he's got to be
[Laughter]
asked trail bro
joe gets pissed off then i'll make go at
it just doing casual runs yeah
um i guess i'm guessing the
environment's a bit like that though
because especially how much you guys
have been training just by yourselves in
the last couple of years you obviously
have to push yourself against each other
pretty hard eh
yeah i think stubbs just doesn't like
losing them
[Music]
competitive
it's a very rarely happens
but yeah like larry said we had a good
year of not being able to play um on the
world series so you know we kind of had
to push ourselves on our own because
especially when you've got no country
so you know i don't know
put the pump on you or yeah
[ __ ] take
[Laughter]
that's good for me like as a playmaker
we kind of had like four playmakers off
four main playmakers that um
like really put the pressure on each
other like especially for kicking line
out throwing passing and stuff like that
we have a challenge every week yeah and
that was just super competitive and like
sometimes you get too competitive with
that like
you can go out the window so you just
get inside your own head yeah and um but
it's me and i think that's why
you know like some of our set pieces
work so well and and some of our
kick-offs and stuff like that goal kicks
and i think that's why it works so well
because we're all pretty similar in
skill level i reckon yeah push each
other hundred percent anything with
money involved
oh he loses it or he steps up
oh the pressure money or dying is
we had a challenge i read a bit and i
think it was hit the crossbar the first
one yeah yeah the first one was hit the
crossbar and i heard the crossfire was
me riggs and billy yeah and i hit the
crossbar and then riggs missed it
and then i didn't think he was going to
do it i was like nah nah we'll make it
best of three so you know he has to die
now it's a big event
and then yeah i ended up losing the next
oh no no the first one was a drop kick
second one was a crossbar
third one was the
basketball air bus was shot yeah and
then i won two and lost one and we're
all on one one each yeah yeah and we see
it right from the start
if it comes down to it we're gonna have
to do a boat race to settle it
it was me having bills
[Laughter]
he's well equipped as well
did you lose by much because i mean
you're pretty decent drinker though
you've been watching them
[Laughter]
read smoke dust i think me and bills
oh that's good stuff and talk to me a
little bit about the flight home from
the olympics obviously grado gave a
little bit of insight about him dressing
in his rowing suit but what was what was
the atmosphere like on that flight home
[Laughter]
um
yeah we got on the plane we got on the
plane and the first you know the pilot
goes over the loudspeaker yeah and he
sort of does his um announcements in his
site
all right i know there's a
charter flight full of athletes you know
building up for this moment for four
years but we can't flip this plane into
a party plane
now we've got regulations you've got to
follow hello yeah okay sweetest
everyone's quite tame and as soon as the
seatbelt simon oh yes
they've been cranked
bottles of whiskey
[Laughter]
[Music]
he was nude
he was on the wrong side when we landed
he stayed in it as well
oh he's a rooster eh
you guys have heaps of good lads in your
um seven squad that way so it must be
must be enjoyable um yeah yeah we've um
yeah we've got a lot of good fellas in
the team
we've spent quite a long long time
trying to build our culture yeah um
trying to get a good balance between you
know switching on and switching off
and i think we're in a pretty good spot
you know like all the boys kind of buy
into most of the things we we kind of
say and do
and it makes everything more enjoyable
especially when you've got that buy-in
it's not perfect but
we're getting there 100
and talk to me about a little about
about 15 so like you're both playing 15s
now you both had very successful sevens
careers is is there a decision for you
guys to make whether to pursue fifteens
or sevens or uh what are your sort of
future plans looking like uh yeah it's a
tough one you know
we always kind of
you sum up between sevens and 15 because
obviously 15 0's we make all the coin
yeah but you know me personally at the
moment i'm pretty um
i'm pretty sure i'm staying with sevens
for as long as i can yeah
obviously if there's any japanese teams
well i'll tell you what these are
a few guys who have
got japanese contracts from coming on
this podcast by just doing what you've
done there just putting the feelers out
so yeah
now the next podcast will be regan's
announcement
to
tokyo
now but your goal is to at the moment to
go with the seven side to the
commonwealth games and the next olympics
is that sort of the plans unless like
you say a big offer comes
yeah yeah like um
like i always say bro like my heart's in
sevens i'm real passionate about sevens
um better team better culture yeah
so you know um
you can't really put money on that that
sort of thing when you when you're fully
invested into something like that
until until
[Laughter]
and now about you
like you've obviously made your name in
the seventh game and now that you've
done that you've come to fifteens and
you've made a seamless transition back
to fifteens carving it up for tasman at
fullback so i'm sure plenty of super
offers or contracts would be available
for both of you if you wanted it but
whether you want to go down that pathway
or not
ah well not not that i've seen
it
not like kind of the same as regs like
obviously never say never but yeah um
like my number one goal at the moment is
to
win gold at the commonwealth games and
then after that hopefully the uh sevens
will cut
um i feel like if i
if i didn't put everything into going to
the next olympics i'd be pretty gutted
yeah yeah i just really want to get that
gold in the olympics so it's my number
one focus um but you obviously never
said never but
um yeah i'm pretty passionate about the
sevens and
it's a shame that
um you know some of the boys don't
don't get more queen either they'll
probably stick around a bit longer but
yeah so it is a tough decision that some
of the boys have to make like
i know a lot of the boys don't
necessarily want to go sometimes but
they're trying to set their families up
and stuff like that so
yeah obviously at the same time very
grateful
[Laughter]
oh mate i'm sure there'll be plenty of
offers coming to you both after this but
like you say it's um cool that you're so
passionate about the side and keen to
get to that next olympics
um so would you do you think you can do
both do you think you could do sevens
for the start of the year and maybe do a
bunnings cap or like are you available
for tasman next year both of you
this contract i could saw that
like i said bro
um
i guess next year is a little bit tricky
because um
the world cup is september the 10th i
think oh yeah
so um
i mean if you want to sign us from then
onwards
mate i'm sure
to see what that schedule looks like but
if we can get one more game out of two
i'm sure the province will be bending
over to get you back
what do you reckon stab king
yes yeah i always love coming back down
here like any chance i get so yeah um
back out to riwaka should you pick
apples on the weekends yeah yeah
recovery yeah living living and you went
out you even tested the waters didn't
you the other weekend rigs you went out
fishing however trips or the
abel tasman waters was it
i don't even think we made it that far
wow yeah we probably picked the wrong
boat
lucky william got a
bloody million-dollar
hard top that was just carved through
the waves
i think we made it about 10 minutes out
of the harbor yeah
parked up for about 10 and then
shut it down
basically surfing waves
[Laughter]
oh next time anyway uh what are your
plans post-footy for both you boys have
you have you looked that far ahead have
you got much of a plan
ah
not as much of a plan as i'd like i
think i i i started uh like a social
working degree um not degree
diploma don't even think it's a diploma
claim the degree
studying social working anyway i think
it was
last year yeah
and about obviously anything
along those sort of lines i'd be pretty
keen to get into yeah like um
getting into sort of trouble troubled
youth work um
something like that bro giving back to
the community something i'm pretty
passionate about as well
would you live in tow is that where you
want to sort of settle after footing i'm
not really too sure what i'd settle you
know you can't really beat them out yeah
um good spider
mountain
[Laughter]
[Music]
um but yeah like i said bro i'd probably
like to have
more of a backup plan than what i do
have yeah kind of just putting all my
eggs into this footy basket at the
moment yeah
um but we'll slowly try and take away
something over the next couple of years
so that old dad doesn't get to
hopefully 38
and what about you
back to the apples
i'm not good at this
um yeah i've got a pretty successful
missus off of shutterstock
what does she do uh she's a studying a
phd at the moment in biology oh wow
right on
yeah so yeah smoker break for me
so if all house fouls fell back
[Laughter]
farm he'll be my dog
i kind of want to stick around like um
you know do something with sevens and
and try grow sevens in new zealand i
feel like yeah there's still a massive
growth that we can have in new zealand i
feel like it may be a good pathway for
for heartland players is probably to go
through that sevens route yeah you know
i remember playing sevens for the the
year i got dropped and like i was
definitely not the best player on that
team like there was some worker talent
yeah and i just feel like sometimes they
they kind of fall through the cracks
because they don't understand the
pathway they can go through or or how
they can get there yeah enough and i
don't know if there's opportunities
there for them to um go a bit further so
i feel like it would be pretty wicked to
to get some heartland boys and like a
black jersey or or even get the chance
to maybe try so i like that yeah i don't
know
the stubby academy getting heartland
players to the top i love it love that
idea both of you want to give back to
the community such lads
anyway guys
um we've gone to the instagram as always
for some questions and double the guess
means double the question so we've got
plenty that have come through
for the lads so first question
regan favorite part about going to the
factory hbhs
oh um
probably going to have a beer with uh
nigel hotham oh yeah is that um noah's
dad yeah yeah he's our first 15 coach
what was he yeah oh quite a lot to that
man sure
um
as long as he brings his guitar and he
buys a box of white cops
nice
love it noah
shout out to noah and his old man okay
um
best villi kroy story
you must have a few
there's a few bro
[Laughter]
i was the first win our first win at a
tournament it was um south africa
and um yeah we had a few beers after and
and he kind of shut the bed away but and
continued first and uh we had to carry
him and stuff like that well like right
over we're gonna drop me off at the
hotel
she'll be sweet and then we dropped them
off and
uh the food chains were gonna piss up at
the hotel so we're pretty much just
feeding him to the line
we get back from town and he's way worse
off than what he was
like well what have we just done
[Music]
oh that's good stuff okay for regan were
you good at touch or sevens uh neither
neither
did you play touch yeah i played a
little bit of touch
you must have been a gun going for this
question no [ __ ] and i was i was a
battler on the wing
i was in there to do the yards and d for
joey and then
summed me off when it comes to attack
did you go to nationals on that because
you guys were always stacked though yeah
we actually won a few nationals there we
go like i said bro i was just there for
yards and d yeah that's important
important important parts love the yards
okay this one for stubby are you still
punching out of your weight division
heavily by the sounds of that laugh
i don't understand the question
um
is your mrs a lot better looking than
you wow
yeah i don't know i mean i guess so
i'm guessing it was a male that sent him
that question yeah it was it's actually
goody's brother
it would have been yeah
then the academy trainers far out
as soon as i got with me it was just
like what's she up to
but 20 years younger than you
but the relationship's going well yup
yup not she's a good sword yeah she's um
she saw that we bought a new house and
she's kind of doing all the papers at
the moment i'm going to bug her all so
she's buying you a house she's good
looking she's she's got a hustling job
i'm obviously not that bad
[Laughter]
okay as andrew's favorite player still
for tony philly
yeah yes big wellington yeah wellington
fan growing up in the cafe yeah
he hit a good long way
okay next one how did riggs get such a
beautiful running technique oh that's
good
this one's andrew goodman the other one
was chris
he loves your stride eh no i do bro no
idea have you done some sprinting
not really no no
we always naturally fast like as a young
kid coming through
when all the school races and all that
sort of stuff when i was
9 or yeah yeah quickest and the quickest
in the school quickest under 10 there
was
what about it um college later on still
the fastest
no you're so humble away
[Laughter]
he's just good at running because he's
running away all the time
and he just couldn't be the slowest to
get caught
did you get in much trouble and tote
because obviously
there's a fair bit of
gang affiliation up there did you ever
get involved in any of that sort of
stuff
uh
yes and no
you know like my mates were kind of
uh
not involved with it at all but yeah you
know we were kind of all little shits
like that yeah
um
trying to rip gangs that we went in
[Laughter]
little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
uh yeah i was pretty much afraid
i was on and off the mischief train
we'll just leave it there yeah
did rugby sort of keep you from going
down that path yeah yeah it did bro
especially going to hamilton yeah i kind
of had the decision to make you know
whether i was going to stand take for
high school or head over to hamilton
thankful that i did kind of make the
transition up to hams you know because i
probably wouldn't be in the place i am
now yeah
how good shout out to hamilton boys
okay next question
stubby what's the worst thing that
happened in the bart simpson room
uh
what's about simpson
yeah my old man's pretty
he's a bit of a craftsman and we kind of
done up this room i built this room and
as a young fellow i kind of had all my
favorite cartoons on there
how old are you
teenagers
have you still got it
yeah he's still
it's still
oh sounds like a hell of a room
okay
this one's from party party
and it's a singing one um i've never
seen regan scala beer
in a chain
okay next one ask regan if he's still
the keys of a man
yeah
what's that what was that one me oh high
school i used to lose my keys all the
time oh i try i'd literally walk into
like one of the bros house sit down with
three minutes
[Laughter]
okay
this one's from the real stubby is riggs
or elisa the third wheel
[Laughter]
the tricycle
is that a bit of a three-way
relationship that one weave it
[Laughter]
yeah we're planning on like
anniversaries and stuff and reeks comes
in what are we up to
that's good stuff and who was andy pam's
andy fans
as uh
yeah that's what my older brother's
trying to it's forcing his like kids who
are like three and two trying to
call me uncle andy pens oh yeah yeah and
it's sticking just because they're real
they're real cute so you got to be like
oh yeah but yeah in the back of my mind
i'm like don't [ __ ] call me
uncle drew
okay who is stabby's favorite claw
brother
himself
are you a official claw brother oh
there's some legends in that grouper
warwick lamert
yeah
yeah they're the famous claw brothers
and yourself
i think i've been born into that group
um
yeah unwillingly
as your brother in it yeah yeah my
brothers
my brother still acts like he's a
17 year old fellow i think
grey here
same height
way better looking
he's an absolute creek oh i mean he's a
great guy
okay is it true that stubby is the son
of horophenol carpeting legend ashley
drake no i'm not but i wish i was jesus
the top man he's a legend day he's been
playing that seventh circuit for
oh
how many years 20 plus yeah probably
yeah cook island international
dj forbes look alike
he's a top man and now my parents had a
bit of a do and and carefully when we
were playing the olympics and and he
rocked up and he was
sculling a few beers i think back with
the old boy watching the olympics so it
was pretty special because he was in um
a few of the um
cupcake teams that i was playing sevens
for so it's cool for him to come and
watch and he was one of the guys that
kind of got me into sevens and he's a
top man true love that okay next one do
they fold or scrunch toilet paper i'm
guessing
how do you wipe them out
[Laughter]
scrunch
okay
andrew what is your favorite stadium to
play it
um
maybe tookenham
is a pretty awesome stadium obviously
there's a lot of history and stuff like
that
um from favorite places would be
vancouver yeah
and that stadium is pretty awesome so
that's that turf i get grazed up
straight away
i'll be in there with the leg skins
[Laughter]
are you going to rip leg skins
yeah
maybe it's an american thing to do
good goodies mate we'll be ruining them
you guys how do you find him how do you
find him and like perry baker and stuff
like that
i don't mind them bro yeah it's
kind of a personality thing
yeah it's just stubby doesn't like them
he hates people who are faster than him
so competitive
okay we've got heaps about this for you
stubby
um why is stubby such a jew
and the other one was who's the biggest
tight ass out of both of you
well it's funny these questions are
popping up because obviously me and eggs
have been living together yeah and yeah
i'm yet to see his card
filling up the car and i'm like slowly
opening up the door like is it me
[Laughter]
i've never seen him at a bar bro
i've never seen him in a bar shouting
around
you get the bears he gets a petrol
we got 20
[Laughter]
okay two more most embarrassing moment
on the field
we're playing it's twickenham money and
we're we're dean on the line
and um i was on the left side and they
kind of faked to go right and then come
back left and i was like geez we're here
and i flew up out of the line
to make a massive spot tickle
and i just jumped at him and then
we both got like he just kind of went
down but i kind of did like a 540 landed
on my head and i was like what have i
just done and i've like definitely come
off second best and we've only got like
i think i was the only plane maker left
so we didn't have any more like subs or
anything and i was just like more like
all dizzy and dicky shoulder and like
he's like what are you doing mate you
just got to smash a huge guy you become
a second beast
i don't know what i was thinking i was
just panicking i need to find that
footage that sounds like one of the
great tackles kamikaze
okay last question one from each of you
best piece of advice that you've got for
our listeners
i know you've both got lots of wisdom up
in those special minds
um
i probably said it a hundred thousand
times but
my big thing is kind of follow what
you're passionate about um
do what you love
love what you do and you know like
for me like
a lot of what i do especially with
sevens comes down to love and passion
like i said
you know you've got the choice whether
you want to branch off and go make money
and 15 sort of things but i kind of
like to stick around sevens because i
love the
i love the game love the culture on our
team
and i'm real passionate about
um everything to do with sevens so
that's probably why i
do a lot of the things i do is because
i'm passionate about it
so there's one piece of advice i'd
probably give is to
kind of follow your heart and do what
you're passionate about love that wow
you've got some big
big shoes to fill after that that was
impressive from big rigs let's go stuff
you've had a good bit of time to think
about yours too so this is going to be
real good
um
this bit of advice
just pick as many apples as you can
[Music]
think maybe just yeah kind of the same
as regs like whatever you're passionate
about just go for it and
i guess
don't listen
um
you know to people that are telling you
that you can't do what you want to do
and
um you know within reason i guess but
[Laughter]
but like if um you know if you want to
be a footy player you know you just
stick at it and
like for me i remember it's been a few
times i'd um you know been told i'll
probably never play for teezy or
um you know i'll never be a professional
rugby player and
i've been lucky to you know there's a
bit of luck involved as well for sure
but yeah i've worked pretty bloody hard
to get to where i am so
um yeah i guess try not to buy into and
try not to believe what people are
trying to tell you all the time um
obviously take advice from people but um
yeah
back yourself yeah yeah yeah confidence
i love that from both of you what a geez
that's still the best piece of advices
on one podcast
what a way to finish it really
appreciate you boys coming on the
podcast
it's been awesome to get to know you
both over the last few weeks coming down
here and applying your trade and giving
like i said at the start so much to the
group and definitely being a big part of
getting tasman into the finals so it's
been awesome to get to know you looking
forward to watching you guys go in the
final and then hopefully celebrating the
next few days with you as well so uh
appreciate you coming on lads cheers
[Music]
[Music]